[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
politique à table sur lcp la seule
émission qui allie agriculture écologie
alimentation mais aussi politiques cette
semaine nous recevons karima delli c'est
vous qui allez passer sur le grill est
avec moi pour présenter cette émission
jean pierre montanay bonjour jean pierre
bonjour brigitte bonjour karima delli
bonjour bonjour karima delli bouger le
député écologiste européenne et
conseillère régionale des hauts de
france une région que vous connaissez
bien puisque vous êtes né à roubaix que
vous avez vécu à tourcoing avant de
faire vos études à lille en dépit d'un
nom à la consonance algérienne par vos
parents vous êtes une vraie ch'tis la
culture de la pomme de terre n'a pas de
secrets pour vous vous nous avez donc
logiquement demander des frites des
frites des frites légendaire oui à ces
ch'tis on ne refera pas et pour
accompagner ses frites une eau blatter
dessert encore des oeufs une crème
brûlée dans le dos ou des plats haro sur
les scandales alimentaires les pizzas
boutonnier les chocolats et kinder sont
montrés du doigt dans les pieds dans le
plat en raison de la guerre en ukraine
les agriculteurs sont autorisés à
cultiver les terres en jachère pour
doper la production agricole vont-ils
jouer le jeu réponse à suivre allez on
passe à table tout de suite cuisine et
confidences
alors karima delli j'ai mis beaucoup de
temps avant de comprendre pourquoi vous
aviez choisi une omelette rien dans vos
origines de l'algérienne ni dans votre
ancrage à roubaix ne serait indiqué
cette passion pour les autres gallinacés
et puis je suis tombé sur cette petite
phrase pour que certaines actions soient
menées à bien il faut accepter certains
sacrifices elle aurait pu très bien vous
le concéderez être tiré de votre
programme ou de l'un de vos discours
vous qui prônez une écologie parfois un
peu punitive vous dites que pour
ralentir le réchauffement il faut faire
preuve de sobriété c'est à dire faire
des efforts et des sacrifices en
pédalant sur son vélo plutôt que de se
la couler douce au volant d'une voiture
qui pollue et bien figurez-vous brigitte
que cette petite phrase est en fait la
définition d'une expression qui datent
du 19e siècle bien avant la naissance du
giec on ne fait pas d'omelette sans
casser des oeufs voilà donc comment
l'omelette est en fait de façon
subliminale au coeur de votre projet
politique elle incarne à vos yeux cette
planète à sauver elle est devenue votre
obsession au point que vous nous
exhorter ici à casser des oeufs pour
vous offrir ce plateau pu leers est
assez écolo dans le fond car il nous
permet de consommer des protéines sans
manger trop de viande n'est ce pas
karima delli absolument sauf que c'est
pas du tout ce que j'attendais
[Applaudissements]
pas mais c'est pas au départ c'était ce
que moi j'ai appelé notamment une
omelette frites c'est à dire on doit
retrouver les frites dans l'omelette et
la vraie à la vraie signification ses
sandwichs
frites omelette donc c'est très bien
parce qu'une baguette au qu'on va le
faire en direct abattoirs
voilà c'est qu'elles sont cuites dans
l'huile et ensuite on verra joue dans le
blog voilà et ensuite on les met dans le
pas pour ça qu'on appelle sandwichs
frites omelette alors pourquoi et d'où
ça vient tout simplement parce que moi
je suis écolo et souvent les écolos ils
sont caricaturés j'aurais pu choisir du
quinoa du no-fault un tueur fou sort y
était attendu la tresse assez la
caricature ou alors on aurait fait un
petit peu le côté trop rigide donc le
couscous mais comme on mange moins de
viande on aurait fait le couscous
légumes etc voilà ça a été sa politique
oui mais c'est moi oui ce sandwich
omelette fritz c'est une signification
c'est le premier repas populaire au fait
qui vient des travailleurs algériens et
diot fait cette tradition remonte donc
de l'algérie mais aussi de mes terres
donc les hôtes france les ch'tis qui
aujourd'hui à une déclinaison incroyable
on appelle ça par exemple mitraillette
mitraillette pour ceux qui me regardent
et qui sont juste ils savent très bien
ce que ça veut dire c'est le sandwich
avec des frites et une merguez par
exemple eh oui ils t'ont merkel n'ont
même pas on peut mais
trouve aussi c'est un peu moi c'est à
dire la frite c'est un peu l'européenne
moi qui ai souvent à bruxelles c'est le
nord mais c'est surtout le repas du
pauvre pourquoi je dis ça mais parce que
fait aujourd'hui ce ce sandwich frites
omelette et énormément consommés par des
étudiants parce que c'est leur pain le
moins cher et le moins cher est assez
nourrissant là vous voyez ce que ça oui
ce sera équilibré alors le fruit non
mais il faut pas faire ça tous les jours
mais en même temps il ya un truc aussi
très sympa c'est le côté très convivial
et vous savez moi je suis la neuvième de
13 enfants est-ce qu'on a tous la même
voie large et je peux vous assurer que
de faire des pique-niques avec des
sandwichs frites omelette c'est un
bonheur et ses proches qu'elle soit
chaude en fait sinon c'est pas très bon
et ben c'est là où on a des parce que
pour les goûters nous dire on a des
solutions non non ça va tiens mais parce
qu'on est très exigeant
que ce soit alors très chaud on aurait
dû l'être j'essaie de voir ben ça donne
mais les fruits de l'omelette comme ça
alors il faut un petit bout de pain
oui alors non je la remets les frites
par dessus moi je le fais voilà on l'a
alors je coupe un morceau de pain bon là
il est passé sans doute mais il a du
coup nos jean-pierre aussi m'atteindre
six ans
le milieu john l'aide d'un millier des
fruits tenons à oui c'est ça qui est bon
l'afrique va va se pénètre helmand dans
le jus de l'omelette et ça va être super
d'accord jean pierre nanterme
moi je te regarde et
je serai là c'est super je suis devenu
charmant dimanche ça c'est pas facile à
manger c'est alors non mais vous savez
quand s'en nourrissent encore immense
avant la wii je suis mr bah voilà elle
va nous manquer alors à l'argenté c'est
bon jean pierre
délicieux super non c'est très bon je le
connais bien et là je sais que je sais
qu'ils trouvent ça très très bon c'est
très bon karima delli baba bon très
bonne idée mais ben voilà bah voilà et
alors vos parents vous faisait ce repas
là quand vous étiez petit bah oui moi
j'ai souvent à la maison bas absolu mots
moi j'adorais en une chose c'est que on
a eu la télé à cet art et vous y avez
quand on a eu la télé c'était le
dimanche soir le dimanche il y avait le
film ce n'est sur les grandes chaînes
très bien et donc c'était le moment
d'avoir un sandwich frites omelette ou à
son lieu devant le film devant le film
donc c'était super votre pop corn à vous
quand un petit peu moi j'ai plein de
beaux souvenirs je trouve que le repas
est un moment exceptionnel au fait alors
on s'était classée 15 à table à la
maison ça 13 enfants qu'un matin midi et
soir voyez les salles ont fermé détruire
ma mère mais il entre chez les pommes de
terre il faut les maintenir lui il faut
les faire cuire ce devait être une usine
à gaz oui mais c'est tout là la beauté
au fait du travail de mes parents et
aussi des grandes monde s'y mettait ça à
la maison folie de cuisiner mais quand
on est à table on était tous à table où
je ressemble voilà et vous alliez à la
friterie vous faisiez les frais la
maison ont coupé les pattes à on
n'allait pas la friterie sauf quand on
allait à bray-dunes alors bray dunes
c'est où ça à côté de dunkerque ont des
vacances et là c'était marrant parce que
c'était les vacances et la friterie y
avait pas les cornées individuel oui
c'était on devait ramener là la bassine
pour pouvoir avoir l'ensemble des frites
pour les quinze personnes et c'était
génial donc tout le monde piocher et
voilà c'est ce que rappelle un peu à
l'algérienne dans le couscous
non c'est juste une méthode aussi de
montrer quelles poules le moment du
repas c'est quelque chose de joyeux
d'enthousiame de sympa et aussi de très
conviviale vous voyez moi je pense qu'on
est dans des moments de vie où le repas
on le zap un peu moi on a perdu ça cool
indien secteur ces voix là alors que je
fais tour du plach je pense ouais et
alors que je pense qu'on a un savoir
faire extraordinaire en france on a des
chefs on a plein de choses moi j'adore
faire à manger j'adore ca de deux
concurrents c'est parce que moi j'adore
aussi faire des gâteaux et des
pâtisseries donc j'ai hâte de
concurrencer le meilleur parti non non
juste parce que papa le meilleur
pâtissier c'est juste par exemple
françois régis gaudry qui un jour a
présenté un cake au citron alors que
tout le monde me dit que je suis je fais
le mail art etc etc au citron c'est vous
donc j'ai hâte de donc je lui lance une
invitation là sur votre tracteur pour
lui dire qu'elle venait le match
on les transmettre à leurs jets
j'adore j'adore recevoir j'adore
cuisiner et il y a un truc que j'aime
bien les ambiances où on est nombreux
mais c'est dû au fait que j'ai beaucoup
de frères et soeur et j'en ai dit alors
qu'est-ce que vous cuisinez ckoi
algérienne votre attachement au nord qui
se mélangent est ce que c'est un peu de
la fusion entre deux on paye à tout le
moins je suis alors je suis aussi la
reine de la déclinaison des pâtes alors
ça je fais des pâtes aux aubergines je
peux faire des pâtes dont je fais des
pâtes dans tout se voit tout et des
déclinaisons
j'adore j'adore aussi les les nouvelles
j'aime bien aussi cuisiner une cuisine
que je connais pas la cuisine asiatique
dames avec des nouilles avec des
raviolis et des ravioles compte
aujourd'hui qu'on garni avec plusieurs
d'herbe et c'est tout ça moi j'adore
quoi et le soulager une par exemple où
le alors les omelettes et je laisse moi
j'adore les omelettes et en même temps
je les décline sur plein de trucs j'aime
bien les omelettes avec plein vous
mettez des herbes et ses réserves des
champignons jambon fromage bûche j'ai
pas de porc je mange pas de pain et puis
j'essaie de pas manger de viande j'ai
pas dit que j'étais végétarienne 1 mais
j'essaie au maximum d'éviter la viande
au jour du zoo j'en mange quasiment plus
je peux même dire voilà 3 3 astuces à
savoir sur l'omelette l'entière
exactement là pour casser les yeux il
faut faire très attention ne faut pas
que des petites morceaux de coquille il
faut il faut les cas c'est à plat voilà
où alors vous voulez casser avec un
autre of life prenait 1,9 vous vous le
poussez et ensuite avec les doigts vous
ouvrez l'offre est comme ça vous limiter
les risques parce que ça peut affecter
votre omelette parce qu'il y avait des
cochonneries sur les petites coquilles
d'oeuf et ensuite rien de mieux qu'une
fourchette ou une double fourchette l
élite pour les battre c'est comme ça
ensuite pour une omelette aryenne vous
pouvez monter les blancs en neige et
ajouter une pointe de bicarbonate
alimentaire pour une omelette très
allégée
incorporez aussi ça c'est une trouvaille
de l'autre pois chiches et pour une
version un peu mousseuse et bien vous
rajouter de l'eau gazéifiée de l'eau
gazeuse et ça vous fait une omelette un
peu un peu à oreille comme ça quant à la
cuisson il ya une autre mais il ya une
autre recette que moi je fais c'est de
mettre aussi un filet de l'est oui
la rampe lyrisme avait aussi beaucoup
plus onctueuse exactement un deuil de la
qui rajoute même de la crème enfin vous
jetez les oeufs battus dans le beurre
bien chaud et il faut cuire à feu assez
vif et pour vraiment faire une belle
omelette un jour j'ai vu le chef il faut
avoir le coup de main c'est à dire que
dans la poêle il faut toujours donner ce
geste là l'omelette va cuire et en même
temps elle va se rouler ce qui fait que
ça oui tout seul avec le mouvement va se
rouler mais c'est très dur et elle va
griller un pur surface est resté très
moelleux à l'intérieur à l'interview à
l'intérieur et on rajoutera bien sûr les
fruits des fruits pardon vous l'aimez
baveuse aussi le mal est profond il faut
qu'elle soit baveuse ans que vous voulez
mettre des fruits ah oui pour les mais
il faut bien savoir une benne une bonne
il faut avoir des bons outils ça c'est
clair notre cuisine vous avez du bon
matériel et des poils j'ai seize balles
j'essaye et ensuite et après il ya deux
écoles aussi dans les omelettes c est ce
qu on fait revenir l'eau menée sur de
l'huile d'olive ou sur du beurre alors
là on n'est pas d'accord au fait moi
j'ai plutôt pendant cette île de lifou
l'huile de lin rachida non non moi
j'aimais bien seul là tout est ouvert ça
c'est vaut sans doute votre tropisme
méditerranéen mais c'est vrai que ce
qu'ils font les tchèques quand ils font
des omelettes dans les bras sont souvent
sommaires voilà on parlera tout à
l'heure du noble est bien connu dans les
quizz elle est faite au beurre mais
l'huile d'arachide qui est un peu en
rupture de stock et l'huile d'olive
peuvent très bien aller pour faire une
omelette fait penser la tortilla qui est
une noble et espagnole et à l'huile
d'olive et ben voila est souvent comparé
justement la tortilla au fait c'est un
peu la même déclinaison que l'omelette
offrit
à la pomme de terre
selon les pays européens on est alors on
va voir si vous êtes vraiment
incollables puisque barré mais
particulièrement la cuisine c'est le
quiz allait oser
alors pour les quizz on est resté sur le
d'autres petits couples frites et
omelette à la calebasse par les frites
on l'a compris vous êtes né au pays des
baraques à frites près où celles ci sont
souvent accompagnées de sauces 1 les
frais alors laquelle karima delli de ces
quatre sauces n'est pas servie dans les
fameuses baraque à frites que vous
fréquentez la sauce banzaï ah
ça existe la sauce ch'ti b la sauce
cause accès et la sauce hannibal des
pieds quoi là je connais pas la sauce
cosaques et ben
n'est pas ça la connaît un fort temps
fritz à la hausse
alors 10e quiz à propos de meules est l
une des recettes les plus connus et
celle de la mère poulard au mont saint
michel laquelle de ces affirmations et
fausses à les blancs sont battus
séparément et ajouté aux jeunes au jaune
b elle est cuite à feu vif dans une
poêle à long manche c'est madame poulard
développe à cette recette après l'avoir
préparé pour le pape en visite inopinée
au mont saint michel c'est vrai c'est
vrai
à dès
1884 le figaro parle d'une omelette
inoubliable alors qu'elle est il passé
en force de ces quatre médecins et fonds
longs blonds manche là y'a un truc avec
le manche s à la poêle au long manche à
c'est peut-être vrai ça attendez le
premier je suis désolé blanc ce sont des
matches à voir séparément et vr que je
suis myope aux jaunes
des blancs sont battus et on rajoute les
jours d'après cette fois on a déjà la
réponse
alors en fait c'était c'est donc c'était
madame poulard développe à cette recette
après l'avoir préparé pour le pape en
visite inopinée au mont saint michel et
ça serait ça c'est faux adacore c'est
flou c'est faux parce qu'en fait tu
avais remarqué que les pèlerins calé au
mont-saint-michel arrivé c'était au
contraire affamés et la façon la plus
facile de leur de les nourrir c'était
lors casser des oeufs dire une omelette
mais pas de pape au mont saint michel
avec la mère poulard c'était faux
d'accord vous ne disiez tout à l'heure
que vous mangez très peu de viande voire
quasiment plus est ce que vous êtes une
vraie écolo vous mangez bio local vous
faites très attention à ce que vous
avais je fais très attention j'ai une
une grande tristesse en ce moment c'est
notamment de voir que les
quand vous allez de sur les marchés vous
trouver des tomates et ça ça m'énerve
parce que même quand vous avez des
enfants ou les petits ils pensent que
dans leur inconscient les tomates c'est
toute l'année alors que non c'est pas
toute l'année donc ça c'est une vraie
tristesse deuxième grande tristesse que
j'ai c'est que les enfants on ne leur
apprend plus les légumes à l'école et au
point que par exemple il y avait violé
gims et ça les connaît pas il est vieux
légumes ou les deux au mazout et de
légumes la saisonnalité mais aussi les
légumes en soit en parle on rit
aujourd'hui à plein d'enfants qui ne
savent pas se reconnaître c'est quoi une
courette d'une aubergine et là il ya un
problème de fond voyez alors que je moi
je suis pour curro ya plus d'éducation à
la nature à l'école et notamment cette
saisonnalité elle est impressionnante et
donc elle vous montre des couleurs et
quand vous êtes dans la cuisine c'est
alain passard qui dit ça mais en fait
vous utilisez tous vos sens c'est le
bruit vous vous sentez vous regardez les
couleurs sont merveilleuses vous avez le
goût oui tout ça doit être réactive et
notamment chez nous en fait alors est-ce
que c'est à l'école où c'est aux parents
de jeunes moi je pense que c'est l'école
qui peut aider apprécié oui mais les
parents il faut pas tout leur donner non
pratique de tous les rues mais encore
faut-il avoir les moyens moi je suis
désolé les classes populaires n'ont pas
forcément les moyens d'avoir cinq
légumes fruits par oui c'est très rare
et légumes et
de talmont presse que cet accord sauf
que je vous dis moi mon deuxième combat
c'est de faire de l'écologie de la
rendre populaire est sympa oui tout à
l'heure vous avez fait une présentation
oui l'écologie punitive pour moi ça
n'existe pas l'écologie politique
mettez-vous pro tarder
mais l'écologie punitive n'existait pas
au fait ne pas faire d'écologie là c'est
punitif et moi je veux la rendre et
c'est ma vie en fait l'écologie pour moi
c'est populaire c'est sympa et donc faut
pas tout donner comme comme responsable
pour moi les responsables c'est pas les
parents en fait c'est déjà allons voir
ce qui se passe de l'autre côté de la
chaîne sur notamment la distribution de
ces légumes d'où ça vient pourquoi on
considère qu'aujourd'hui le bio c'est
trop cher je vous y vivent tous n'a pas
accès au bio d'un repas populaire peu
cher là le bio tout le monde sait pas
l'appareil est donc c'est pour ça qu'il
faut faire en sorte que demain par
exemple peut commencer à des échelles
dans les cantines pour nos enfants dans
l'est dans les maisons de retraite
pourquoi tout ça qu'ils sont des
personnels des personnes fragiles on
commence un peu tout de suite eh ben
pour moi le bio ça d'être la priorité le
100 % bio ça doit être l'accent est
ensuite moi je considère que c'est quoi
alors l'état doit aider s'il faut aider
les agriculteurs bio allons-y on a une
fenêtre de tir extraordinaire le
problème que nous avons c'est le c'est
pas la faute des agriculteurs
voyez les agriculteurs sont rentrés dans
un système où on leur a dit il faut
produire produire produire à bas se
produire c'est utiliser des pesticides
des hongres exclus rare par l'epa voyais
on parlait déjà cher tout à l'heure je
leur ai l'occasion effectivement donc
c'est pas la détention matin dans l'est
municipalité et oui je n'ai pour qu'ils
aient des produits bio est un bien
effectivement on le voit le bio est cher
on va d'ailleurs bien les l'aller les
magasins bio se casse la figure ils ont
moins de clients et
c'était qu'au système fonctionne moins
bien car oui mais plus on va produire du
bio et plus les prix seront moins chers
la véritable question aussi elle parce
qu'on va s'attaquer à l'agro-industrie
et là ça reviendra justement tout à
l'heure peut-être va en parler de
scandale alimentaire là on a un problème
de fond est ce qu'on va vraiment
aujourd'hui s'attaquer à
l'agroalimentaire parce qu'on part
pendant on parle de marque comme ça la
ni kinder et compagnie sauf que
derrière ces déesses l'est et derrière
c'est des grandes sens elle vous voyez
on va pas juste leur dire oh la la c'est
l usine qui n'a pas fonctionné et bon
après c'est plus dans un tout petit
instant mais alors ça vous savez qu'en
france le repas occupe une assez large
place particulièrement politique et
c'est souvent là que se nouent des deals
politique et que ce fait la petite et la
grande histoire c'est la brève de
comptoir
et on vous a demandé karima delli de
réfléchir vous de vous rappeler d'une
anecdote autour d'un repas en politique
est ce qu'il ya un souvenir qui vous est
revenu absolument pas
non moi quand on me parle de premier
restaurant c'est marrant mais au fait
moi mon premier restaurant c'était quand
j'ai peut-être beaucoup plus jeune je me
souviendrai toujours c'était le flunch
de roncq donc rond que c'est une ville à
côté de tourcoing et j'avais trouvé ça
extraordinaire qu'on nous dise c'est à
volonté je tombais sardine est que les
enfants ils adorent ça il se précipite
ils valent à remplir votre vie d'une
part c'est pas écolo mais surtout c'est
dans l'imaginaire on pouvait se dire on
paie une fois et on se serre et au fait
qu'il y avait un truc que je n'ai jamais
oublié en fait cette première ce premier
sentiment de dire ah bon on peut tout
goûté au fait c'est pas le web fun ou
consomment c'est le goût vous voyez
c'est pas pareil que ce qu'on voit le
prix à laquelle tu claques en toi là
c'était bon goûter des choses qui
étaient là à portée alors à presles dans
les airs dans les dents les repas
politique ça m'est arrivé à après je
j'ai eu la chance de rencontrer vous
savez des personnalités que je n'avais
mais que je ne pense et je n'aurais
jamais pensé côtoyé vous savez j'ai
travaillé au sénat le sénat un
restaurant extraordinaire avec une carte
extraordinaire c'est très
pour quelqu'un comme moi qui n'ai moi je
n'étais pas fait pour rentrer en
politique je n'ai pas de socialisation
politique mais par en dessous joue
jamais intéressé à la politique la
politique était trop loin pour moi vous
voyez c'était inaccessible et moi je ne
me voyais pas du tout dedans et
finalement j'ai fait une thèse en
sciences politiques que mon objet de
recherche était le sénat français donc
voilà et donc je suis donc j'étais
attaché parlementaire de marie christine
blandin est ce qui était extraordinaire
dans ce restaurant du sénat c'est que je
vous voyais des personnalités que je
n'aurais jamais côtoyé si je n'aurais
pas été
dans cette sphère de la science
politique vous voyez je voyais des
jeunes est à côté de moi un robert
badinter voyez vous le dites c'est
robert badinter je voyais j'avais croisé
comme ça
aussi je me souviens parce qu'elle était
passée juste pour un colloque
gisèle halimi et vous vous dites c'est
incroyable moi j'ai plutôt vous voyez
des souvenirs de deux personnages rampe
et finalement inaccessible et de me dire
waouh fait c'est possible et c'est pour
ça que je suis très contente de me dire
je voudrais dire à toutes les personnes
qui se sentent éloignés de la politique
souvent elles pensent que la politique
c'est pas fait pour elle parce que c'est
trop loin il ya trop d'embûches c'est
inaccessible faut avoir les bons vieux
c'est pas vrai c'est pas parce qu'on
vient de classes populaires qu'on n'a
pas notre place en politique au
contraire vous voyez et aujourd'hui
c'est une grande fierté de manger
une omelette frites et de dire à tous
sur l'ensemble de l'assemblée nationale
en plus à la journée nationale de 10
voilà il faut prendre son destin en main
et surtout les femmes ça je tiens à leur
dire n'attendez pas qu'on vous donne des
places mais c'est un milieu difficile le
talent oui peut-être moi je suis la
première femme présidente de la
commission transports au sein du
parlement européen voyez et en même
temps n'attendez pas les posts on allait
prenez les rayons c'est à vous allez
chercher à les chercher et ne n'attendez
pas qu'on vous les donne maintenant
c'était de nous deux de faire notre
place et nous sommes autant légitime que
les hommes et nous avons aujourd'hui une
volonté aussi de montrer à quel point
nous n'avons pas besoin de quémander
alors on en parlait tout à l'heure de
ces scandales alimentaires on y revient
puisqu'ils ont éclaté en nombre ces
dernières semaines alors y at il eu
négligence de la part de qui comment
éviter que ça ne se reproduise c'est le
dessous des plats
alors oui après cette série noire dans
l'alimentaire a qui a touché certains
grands groupes ferrero but tony
notamment des questions se posent pour
le consommateur
la législation est elle assez efficace
pourquoi les rappels de produits
incriminés sont si l'on a déclenché ces
multinationales sont elles suffisamment
contrôlés et punis en matière d'hygiène
éléments de réponse avec hélène
bonduelle
les pizzas fraîches up de buitoni 52
enfants contaminés par la bactérie
e-coli dont deux sont décédés les
chocolats kinder 150 contamination à la
salmonelle en europe 42 en france
deux nouveaux scandales sanitaires qui
en rappelle un autre celui des les
infantile lactalis contaminés à la
salmonelle en 2017 38 bébé hospitalisé
un retrait des produits bien trop tardif
et un manque de communication criant du
pdg
gregory b sont moroses s'en souvient
bien il était rapporteur de la
commission d' enquête parlementaire
lactalis il y a quatre ans en altérer
les soins moitié puisque moi j'avais
préconisé à plusieurs objectifs qui
étaient déjà de renforcer les auto
contrôle industriel se doit aujourd'hui
se contrôler lui-même ou tassé par delà
des laboratoires qui le contrôler et
puis s'il ya un défaut réparer ce défaut
à l'époque l'état n'était pas au courant
du résultat de ses autocontrôles dans la
loi j'ai demandé ce que les autocontrôle
soit forcément transmis aux services de
l'état ce qui nous permet nous de
connaître ce qu on appelle les zones
chaudes de savoir s'il ya des régions
des départements où il ya un risque
supérieur en revanche moi j'avais
demandé d'autres modifications de la loi
pour faciliter le rappel et on voit
aujourd'hui ses habits casser ces
mesures là nous ne les avons pas
appliquées le député recommandait que
les codes barres des produits soient
remplacés par des qr codes plus précis
avec les numéros de lots selon lui cela
permettrait de sortir plus rapidement du
circuit un produit contaminé et de
contacter les consommateurs quant aux
contrôles une directive européenne de
2002 oblige pourtant déjà les
industriels à communiquer leurs
contrôles positifs à une contamination
le problème selon les ong food watch qui
milite pour une alimentation saine et
durable c'est que ce système est encore
trop des failles ont réalisé a
posteriori et dans une trop grande
opacité l'obligation des entreprises que
ce soit dans le cas de nestlé ou de
ferrero
manifestement n'a absolument pas été
remplies je suis incapable de vous dire
à quel moment ils ont des failles et
puisque le problème c'est justement
qu'il n'y a pas de transparence et donc
ce système qui permet à des géants de
l'industrie agroalimentaire de tout
simplement de rendre au camp compte sur
les quand est ce qu'ils ont fait des
contrôles est ce qu'ils ont eu une
alerte eux-mêmes interne est-ce qu'ils
ont informé les autorités etc ça n'est
pas acceptable parce que c'est la
recette pour la répétition des scandales
le lg a d'ailleurs lancé une pétition
pour demander que ces contrôles soient
rendus publics elle dénonce aussi un
manque de moyens de l'état pour
superviser ces inspections sanitaires à
la répression des fraudes la dgccrf on
parle de plus de 440 postes supprimés
sur ces dix dernières années sur les
contrôles qui sont faits par la
direction générale de l'alimentation on
voit qu'il ya une réduction du nombre
contrôle d'un tiers depuis la sphère
lactalis un site unique rappel conso a
été mise en place pour répertorier les
marchandises incriminées une dizaine de
produits peuvent ainsi être rappelés
chaque jour mais est ce vraiment aux
consommateurs de faire le tri ou à
l'industriel de le prévenir directement
alors qu'areva 17 bonne question est ce
que c'est au consommateur de faire ces
démarches ou aux industriels de balayer
devant leur porte mais moi je crois que
surtout c'est que ça suffit plus de dire
faut rappeler tel et tel produit ça
marche plus au fait vous voyez un moment
faut pas du poing sur la table c'est à
dire que les sanctions doivent être
exemplaires pour l'instant il n'y a pas
eu réellement elles sont pas assez
dissuasives parce qu'il met en exergue
il ya des sanctions oui mais oui mais
elles sont vraiment minimes par rapport
à ce qu'on voit dans votre reportage et
surtout ça touche des enfants et autant
des ddc vous rendez compte mais est-ce
qu'il faut pas amélioré plutôt le
fooding donc d'abord il faut plus vous
renforcez moi je le dit
produit incriminé ne resteront pas dans
les étals quand même bien sûr mais il
faut des sanctions et la dame le dit
très bien il faut des contrôles
renforcés après c'est pas pareil avec
lactalis parce que lactalis lorsqu'on
parle du lait d'amont pasteurisé ou
pasteurisé ça rien à voir vous voyez là
on parle de produits ou la chaîne
notamment agro industrie doit absolument
aujourd'hui être travaillés et c'est là
où il faut mettre le paquet sur la
question des contrôles et des sanctions
alors il ya des autocontrôles qui
existent mais foodwatch dit il sont pas
rendus publics donc finalement on ne
sait pas est-ce que déjà vous sur le
principe de l'autocontrôle
s'autocontrôler est ce que vous trouvez
que c'est efficace est ce que est ce
qu'ils sont assez fréquents ces autos
mais là il ya un problème aussi éthiques
d'ailleurs c'est nous qui allons devoir
contrôler les produits pour pouvoir les
manger non mais à l'état d'aller
contrôler les prud'hommes et on a
l'impression que on remet la faute aux
guillemets ou la responsabilité sur le
consommateur alors que non c'est la
chaîne d'avant c'est à dire les
industriels doivent être responsables et
c'est là aussi où la transparence va
jouer sur les études par exemple
tout ça ça va être aussi renforcé moi
j'espère aussi que demain c'est pas un
qr code qui va changer la donne au fait
ça permettrait peut-être de rappeler
quand même deux prévenus les gens en
urgence si toutefois il ya une
défaillance ça peut arriver que de bonne
foi il ya un problème sur un produit non
ça peut arriver mais je veux dire ça ne
suffira pas pour endiguer comme celui-là
moins que ce que les problèmes là il est
structurelle vous voyez c'est ce que je
vous ai dit tout à l'heure ça c'est ça
peu un petit peu être une des solutions
mais ce n'est pas la remise à plat
totale du de la structure et notamment
du processus et donc il faudrait
multiplier les contrôles se renforce et
à renforcer les contrôles faire en sorte
que les instituts notamment soient
transparents aussi avant le public tout
c'est bien sûr le ses contrôles sur sa
ce soit très transparent mais bien sûr
autrement vous tant que vous n'avez pas
de la transparence même en termes de
recherche etc il ya un moment ou à un
autre vous n'allez pas à tomber les
scandales pour un bac final mans n'a pas
anticipé c'est ça le principe aussi de
précaution il faut anticiper pour
pouvoir faire en sorte débat kono le
citoyen fiscaux l'état a supprimé 4 140
postes en disant à peu près base un
problème en fait c'est un coach je suis
costaud de contrôler le fonctionnaire
pourra assurer c'était bien sûr c'est un
des grands problèmes au fait vous voyez
un moment quand vous êtes sur la route
vous avez pas contrôler votre voiture
vous pouvez pas rouler au fait eh bien
là c'est pareil au fait vous pouvez pas
mettre sur le marché des produits n'ont
pas été contrôlés et là qu'on met
directement en cause quand même
l'industrie agroalimentaire comme si
finalement il y avait besoin de
contrôler parce qu'elle n'était pas
clean au départ pas le problème de fond
c'est qu'on va attendre combien de
scandales alimentaires là aujourd'hui
c'est 8 ni avec kinder et compagnie mais
il ya eu et a encore un an c'était je
crois des lasagnes de lactalis au 6e
passage à la
série noire voyez on peut pas se
permettre aujourd'hui on est au 21ème
siècle de se dire que ça existe mais moi
le drame que je trouve inacceptables
inacceptables ces comptes envers des
décès ou des pathologies qui aimeraient
de grave alors l'état délégués aussi des
contrôles insu ce prix c'est ce qu'est
un troll aux industriels oui est ce que
cette confiance là elle doit être doit
être conservée est ce qu'on n'a pas
intérêt et bacchus à reprendre en main
mais alors ce n'est pas en supprimant
des postes de contrôleurs qu'on y arrive
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que préconise
votre partent à l'heure où justement
d'autres mais vous savez c'est là où on
a un véritable problème de gouvernance
d'état et ça a été un des grands
révélateur par exemple de la ferme à
keynes et depuis quand ce sont des
cabinets de recherche qu'on paye un bras
qui viennent nous dire ce qu'on doit
faire c'est du conseil je suis là ou pas
les we may et préconisations déjà un
c'est très cher mais de 2 c on doit être
dans la vraie vie on est des
responsables politiques dans
responsables politiques à responsable
est donc un moment il faut aller voir
les acteurs il faut plus embaucher et ça
a été dit faut faire du contrôle on
essayait d'avoir sept ans qu'on n'a pas
dans le sens de l'état et qu'il faut
faire appel à des compétences
extérieures qui peuvent permettre de
prendre la décision et on trouvera
toujours ils trouveront toujours des
excuses pour dire on n'a pas eu le temps
n'a pas bien là sa demande véritablement
sait comment fait d'eux les policiers
lors de ce qu'il faut faire congrès
prévu par la convention prendre ses
responsabilités vous dites c'est à
l'état d'aujourd'hui d'aller fallait
d'aller faire les contrôles eux mêmes de
faire la transparence pour dénoncer
quand il faut bahia ça et puis surtout
le fait pas ce que vous me dites mais
alors madame délit vous demandez quoi
moi je demande plus de transparence ça
veut dire techniquement il faut aussi
des blessés c'est une chose la demande
et après il faut l'imposer vous dit que
oui mais moi je ne pense pas donc
comment on le fait les sanctions c'est
ça moi je pense que tu es sanction donc
d'abord il faut embaucher plus de
contrôle donc plus de gens la deuxième
chose c'est qu'il faut des méthodes de
travail comment ça se fait
qu'aujourd'hui sur sa par exemple il
n'ya pas moi je n'ai jamais vu de débat
national sur notamment la question de
l'agriculture de cette agro industrie et
c est ce qu on nageait moi je n'ai
jamais vu il ya plein débat des dons on
à dire qu'on nous dit qu'on est loin des
citoyens industrie alain andré
agroalimentaire pour ne pas les faire
confiance moi je dis aujourd'hui elle a
des comptes à rendre elle a des comptes
à rendre là on parle de famille on parle
de mort de décès et ensuite de ça on est
sur des produits bien ciblé donc tout le
monde va dire on sur le produit et
circuler irena ce n'est pas ça c'est le
phénomène aujourd'hui de remise à plat
de quelle politique à l'école nous
voulons c'est l'aliment l'avenir que la
sécurité alimentaire elle est pas
pleinement assurée dans notre pays
pourrait bien ça veut dire techniquement
on peut plus prendre de risque et ça
veut dire qu'il faut renforcer les
contrôles renforcés aussi les sanctions
qui doivent être exemplaires voyez
aujourd'hui les sanctions elles sont par
exemple ces problèmes d'hygiène un butin
d'épouvantables on a vu des images
c'était dégoûtant et sia est ce que la
course à la rentabilité est à vos yeux
une des raisons des responsabilités de
ces manquements ah oui parce
qu'aujourd'hui on est plus sur la
quantité que la qualité voyez donc la
question aussi des coûts va être un des
enjeux majeurs dans les années à venir
et en nettoyant produire plus pour un
oreiller la valeur donc il faut faire
attention ça veut dire quoi conduire les
équations à résoudre non mais la
question elle est comment on produit
aussi de manière beaucoup plus de
proximité par exemple quand vous
connaissez votre fromage et et vous
savez un peu c'est technique c'est un
petit peu mieux que d'aller acheter dans
une grande force surface un fromage dont
vous ne savez même pas comment il a été
produit vous voyez vous dites des
entreprises pour acheter des produits
tout faits il faut davantage cuisiner
avec des produits locaux bien sûr il
faut être dans la proximité dans des
produits beaucoup plus locaux on a des
coopératives moi je considère que les
amap sont des véritables levier d'action
mais les amap elles sont pas partout aux
fêtes et dans les quartiers populaires
moi je suis désolé à part d'avoir des
comment on appelle ça des d aldi et lidl
et compagne c'est pas normal moi je fais
google ce n'est pas normal parce que
quand vous voyez tous ces produits c'est
des produits pour les populations et les
classes populaires ou citoyens très
prochainement tation à deux vitesses que
vous dénoncez bien sûr pourquoi les
pauvres n'aurait pas le droit à une
alimentation de qualité au sol voyez
c'est ce n'est pas juste c'est et c'est
là où l'écologie pour moi est très
importante c'est à dire l'écologie c'est
pas un luxe pour les bobos voyez
l'écologie c'est pour tout le monde et
c'est d'abord pour les plus pauvres
d'entre nous pourquoi parce que quand on
s'attaque pas au climat ou à
l'environnement c'est les pauvres qui
vont payer et c'est les pauvres qui
trinquent et ben moi je ne suis pas
d'accord moi je considère qu'il ya des
priorités et ses populations sont
prioritaires et je regarde ma région
vous voyez ma région est une région où
malheureusement le taux de chômage est
très fort le taux d'obésité explose on
est la seule région par exemple on a
trois ans d'espérance de devis de moins
que les autres régions
que les autres régions et l'âge muller
tout le monde et c'est marrant parce que
tout le monde a le le débat de la
retraite mais ça se question là nous on
meurt trois fois trois ans de moins
parce que justement qu'il ya des
conséquences sanitaires alimentaire
environnementale mais tout le monde
devrait être dans la rue en raison mais
voilà une véritable justice bon là ont
bien entendu et un eagle sur le plateau
de politique à table alors vous nous
dites il faut produire plus de bio en
tout cas la commission européenne a
autorisé à exploiter des terres qui
devrait en principe qui devait rester en
jachère pour assurer notre sécurité
alimentaire mais avec la réintroduction
de produits phytosanitaires on en parle
et on met les pieds dans le plat
l'ukraine et la russie ne sont plus le
grenier à blé du monde depuis la guerre
des exportations de céréales en
provenance de ces pays sont limitées
alors pour faire face à cette baisse de
l'offre est bien la commission
européenne a autorisé pour l'année 2022
la culture des terres laissées en
jachère une autorisation qui ne séduit
guère les agriculteurs reportage clément
perreault
christophe grison est agriculteur
céréalier dans l'oise il est à la tête
d'une exploitation de 210 hectares dont
10 sont laissés en jachère
voir jean de gaulle âmes et je devrai
rla une jachère qui font environ 7
hectares d'un seul tenant
j'ai d'implanter depuis trois quatre ans
donc on a une belle herbe cette parcelle
il a désormais l'autorisation de la
remettre en culture c'est une décision
de bruxelles pour augmenter la
production européenne dans le contexte
de la guerre en ukraine sauf que pour
l'agriculteur le jeu n'en vaut pas
vraiment la chandelle j'ai une très
belle jachère avec un beau couvert il va
falloir le broyer donc avec un tracteur
ya une tondeuse un désherbants à base de
glyphosate avec malheureusement une
forte dose pour te détruire l'herbe
passage d'outils labour outils adam pour
refaire la structure semi donc dépenses
de semences défense d'engrais pour faire
pousser la culture s'ajoutent à ça le
prix du gasoil effectivement pour les
tracteurs qui est passé de 70 centimes
l'année dernière à 1,086 j'ai fait un
calcul effectivement entre le plus le
moins il n'y a pas grand chose à gagner
sauf si vraiment la dérogation était
plus longue dans le temps où je me dis
bon à l'époque 4 5 ans avoue le coup
dans le cultiver ce chantier quand même
de cet état
[Musique]
cette dérogation sur les jachères n'est
valable que pour 2022 et uniquement pour
les cultures de printemps difficile de
lancer de grandes manoeuvres dans ces
conditions
pourtant les agriculteurs de l'oise
serait équipé pour produire plus
voici l'une de leur coopérative val
france
christophe grison en est le président
ces silos peuvent stocker jusqu'à 20000
tonnes de céréales de quoi voir venir
si on doit collecter plus la moisson
on peut s'arranger que les transports
pour expédier en même temps qu'on reçoit
du coup le tonnage leurs surplus sera
absorbée techniquement c'est possible de
recevoir davantage de sérieux seulement
à l'image de christophe grison les
agriculteurs ne se bousculent pas pour
mettre en culture leurs jachères nous
avons 23 administrateurs et
administratrice qui sont tous
agriculteurs agricultrices
j'ai posé la question et la totalité des
administrateurs m'ont répondu non ce
n'est pas intéressant techniquement peu
car ces jachères sont passés dans les
mauvais endroit des terres pas
productive ce n'est pas intéressant pour
une dérogation si courte
derrière les fed annonce cette mesure
sur les jachères a pour le moment des
effets limités sur le terrain
[Musique]
vous venez de le voir karima delli la
remise en culture des terres en jachère
n'enthousiasme pas tellement les
agriculteurs est ce que c'était une
mauvaise décision non une bonne décision
car oui parce que au fait la gère ses
intérêts un gros gros logique écologique
en même temps au fait de laisser la
terre se régénérer c'est quelque chose
de très important parce que quand vous
accompagnez vos terres justement ça
permet demain d'éviter d'utiliser quoi
des engrais et les engrais en dépendent
qui aujourd'hui bas aussi des russes est
donc oui c'est la spirale infernale et
là on ne nous dit bien on le sait
peut-être pas été dit dans votre
reportage mais l'europe elle demande
juste les fameux 4 % des terres donc
c'est pas grand chose au fait vous voyez
moi je pense que dans une vision à long
terme il va falloir revenir à la jachère
alors je sais que l'art glace et
temporaire pour produire plus pour parer
à cette guerre mais il fallait vous de
ce court j'ai l'impression que vous
n'avez pas tout à fait compris la
question brigitte vous dites je suis
d'accord pour les jachères mais brigitte
poser la question est-ce qu'il fallait
remettre en culture ces jachères la
temporairement il fallait le faire mais
bien sûr que oui pourquoi il faudrait
pas le faire non mais parce que ça
fonctionne pas en fait non mais c'est
pas l'heure c'est pas que ça fasse enfin
on ne sait pas que ça fonctionne pas
c'est qu'il va falloir avoir un plan de
prospective sur sa en agriculture c'est
à dire que à chaque fois on dit il faut
faire ça les les agriculteurs ne savent
pas comment faire au fait non pas parce
qu'ils ne savent pas juste pourri ce à
quoi s'est posée lien d'accord pour
remettre ces cultures en jachère
temporairement
alors sur le sien mais après vous dites
il faudra quand même qu'il y ait des
jachères pour faire respirer la terre
whissell s'est aimé de tous maintenant
on sera dans un processus et
l'agriculture c'est un processus qui
devrait être sur du long terme oui mais
se rapproche des dix nations elle est là
du tout efficace puisque on voit bien
que les agriculteurs veulent pas mais
parce que el cheikh s'est mal ficelé
tout ça finalement oui mais pas ce que
fait moi on peut comprendre les
agriculteurs parce que ça leur fait peur
aux fêtes et qu'ils ont des habitudes et
s'est récemment fait peur c'est que ça
leur coûte très cher en plus donc il ya
aussi c'est pour ça que l'inter roi karl
rove
acteur voilà alors c'est plutôt
sanitaire acheter puis c'était surtout
des terres qui est avait mise en jachère
qui n'était pas très exploitable qui
était pas très rentable donc ils les
avaient laissées près d'un prêt d'une
forêt près d'une rivière et maintenant
remettre une production ça leur coûte
très cher donc effectivement comme c'est
pour cela sans doute été mal ficelé à le
préparer ya pas mal préparés mais aussi
faut des plans d'accompagnement pour nos
agriculteurs on est dans une situation
très dure en france souvent on pense que
les écologistes ont contre les
agriculteurs n est absolument pas on
sait aujourd'hui vivre dans de ce métier
là est difficile donc il faut
accompagner les agriculteurs leur
montrer que la transition et koloma
passer par les hr ou l'agroécologie
faudra leur dire et ensuite il faut que
moi je tire la sonnette d'alarmé si vous
permettez sûr il faut inviter la jeune
génération aussi assez nouveau métier de
paysan et c'est parce que nous sommes
dans un moment aussi de vie où on est en
train de perdre des nombre de paysans
est catastrophique en france alors que
c'est un métier de la terre collègues
écoles le fond plein
l'école oui mais encore faut-il après
qu'on a la relève voiliers et va
regarder
différemment souvent voilà mais n'ont
pas forcément toutes les exploitations
de leurs parents
sur la fibre agricole voilà mais le
retour à la terre va nous amener
énormément d'emplois local non
délocalisables et ensuite de ça va aussi
devoir vous savez de moi dans ma région
et je connais plein de gens qui ont
cette vocation à travailler la terre et
son papa c'est forcément sur des sur des
vins des lycées agricoles mais ils ont
eu la bonne information au bon moment et
cetera voyez ça aussi il faut vraiment
qu'on l'encouragent et ensuite il faut
permettre aux jeunes agriculteurs au
jeune paysanne aux jeunes qu'ils ont de
pouvoir vivre de leur travail et là
c'est un là je le dis c'est parfois très
difficile parce que même le salaire
minimum ils ne l'ont pas ils ne l'ont
pas et sont allemandes étayer vos dit
est acquis de faire un effort à ce
moment-là à l'industriel d'acheter plus
cher à l'intermédiaire au consommateur
est d'abord et s'est établie à un petit
peu plus mais bon il aurait fallu revoir
il fallait revoir là la politique de la
pac en france je veux dire la france et
une reçoit des milliards d'euros elle
doit être orienté vers le bon le bien le
projet la production l'auteur l'avait vu
les échos régime soit attribué aussi à
achever ou à la haute valeur
environnementale et plus seulement au
bio ça ça vous ça vous désespère j'ai
envie de dire un petit peu parce que moi
je ne comprends pas pourquoi on avait su
pas tout de suite sur le le meilleur oui
on a toujours ses petites étapes un
moment faut accompagner mais allons vers
le milieu à wohlen un peu le bio vrai ce
que vous dites enfin samassa mais tu
n'essaies de plus six mais c'est surtout
c'est que tous ces paysans qui sont dans
la dans le dans le bios un moment s'ils
sont pas aidés ils vont mettre la clé
sous la porte alors que c'est dans
certaines filières voyez voilà donc un
moment il faut aussi les aider et c'est
extraordinaire de pas pouvoir les aider
dans le pays de la gastronomie vous
savez moi j'ai la chance au niveau
européen tout le monde me parle à mes
collègues allemands belges italie tout
le monde regarde la france avec ce plus
sait on mange bien en magasin des
français voilà donc si on peut se
permettre aujourd'hui d'avoir un
véritable
une véritable volonté d'avoir des
objectifs concrets sur la question de la
réduction des pesticides vous rendez
compte le grenelle de l'environnement
c'est en 2007 c'était paillade à
millions d'années un demi avait déjà dit
de réduire de la moitié des des
pesticides en france est ce qu'on l'a
fait on l'a pas fait mais vous voudriez
vous aider les agriculteurs mais vous
êtes pour l'interdiction du glyphosate
aujourd'hui pour les agriculteurs
laon produits phytosanitaires mais parce
qu'on a des sept religieux savez quand
on est ministre 1 on anticipe ont fait
pas des annonces comme ça en dix ans -
dans trois engins claude dufau that
bancourt n'arrête le glyphosate ça veut
dire on met en place la filière pour
pouvoir en sortir d'accord on fait pas
juste des annonces pour se faire plaisir
parce qu'au bout de trois ans on n'est
pas sorti du glyphosate on n'a jamais
utilisé autant de pesticides donc un
moment il ya tout cette sphère de l'agro
écologie qui faut pour sexe un problème
de responsabilité politique ce que vous
dites oui et puis aussi de vision vous
voyez on pas c'est pour ça que moi j'ai
un petit peu un problème sur le double
langage on se fait plaisir avec des
annonces mais on va pas se donner les
moyens pour y arriver doxi on sait pas y
arriver on à être les annonces vous
voyez ci auront fait une annonce on met
en place toutes les dispositions pour
pouvoir en sortir nous plaignons fait
pas on planifie l'écologie mais c'est ça
mais on fait pas les grands discours
vous allez voir dans trois ans on va
arrêter le glyphosate
cenasa d'une part ça sert à rien et en
plus de ça c'est la crédibilité de la
parole politique et la bei a pas de
parole politique voilà c'est comme ça
qu'on et délégitimé envoyez moi je
trouve au sommet de la station on peut
pas on peut plus se permettre ça c'est
juste une petite question il ya la
guerre en ukraine grenier à blé 1 qu'est
ce que vous auriez préconisé si vous
aviez été au pouvoir pour redorer
relancer la production agricole en
france pour subvenir à nos besoins vous
auriez laissé en l'état comme ça vous
non mais d'abord je tiens à juste
attirer votre attention sur le fait que
le problème en ukraine aujourd'hui va
avoir des impacts partout dans le monde
ressort une conscience engagé toi même à
l'amérique du nord pour ça que c'est là
où moi je pense que j'aurais été au
niveau ministériel aurait tapé à la
porte de l'europe entend comment on crée
nous maintenant notre notre grenier
européen avec peut-être d'autres
partenaires quand vous regardez gallas
et des besoins immédiats le gros des
européens sélectionnés ailleurs vous dit
le bien sûr le canada par exemple ils
ont des stats extraordinaire etc vous
voyez mais ça ce sont des discussions à
avoir avec une vision là on peut pas
dire à nos agriculteurs aujourd'hui bon
on sait pas ce qui va se passer
maintenant il n'ya pas d'il ya personne
qui dit on accueille tout le monde
autour de la table il ya la transition
écologique à faire quel est notre quels
sont vos objectifs combien on va sortir
d'ici là de pesticides on arrête le
glyphosate on va faire en sorte d'être
beaucoup plus dans la souveraineté
alimentaire c'est très important la
souveraineté alimentaire vous voyez ça
mais moi personnellement je n'ai pas
entendu où sont les acteurs autour de la
table et ensuite vous savez moi je suis
européenne alors que je travaille avec
tout le monde
trouver des bons compromis par le haut
et alors on attend quoi en france pour
travailler aussi sur des bons compromis
et ensuite il ya des régions aussi et
les territoires il ya des exemples
verser le dépassement finalement je sais
pas si je suis sur ça mais il ya des
exemples extraordinaire il ya des
agriculteurs qui ont fait des
reconversions extraordinaire et merci à
eux qui sont des exemples incroyable
mais on n'en parle pas voyez alors que
pour être des modèles et justement il
pourrait presque être un petit peu nos
besoins ambassadeur pour accompagner les
autres quoi alors karima délai vous à
l'arrêt plein de choses à nous dire mais
on a fini le sandwich au fruité à
l'omelette aux maintenant on va passer
au dessert et c'est le péché mignon
alors brigitte à le péché mignon c'est
aujourd'hui une crème brûlée on a déjà
eu des invités qui voulaient des crèmes
brûlées donc j'ai déjà raconté que ce
dessert c'est sans doute les catalans
qu'ils avaient affronté les français il
mettait une pelle dans le dans le feu de
bois très chaude et il venait brûler la
crème c'est pour ça qu'il ya cette
petite cristallisation ce petit caramel
ça remonte à quand la première crème
brûlée de kariba des lycéens souvenirs
d'enfance ah ouais c'est sûr oui on
s'est régalé même plat un plat régressif
euros à 98 pas crier dessus c'est
toujours un bonheur au fait il est là
c'est brillant est envoyé
oui parce que bien c'est vraiment beau
non votre papa qui faisait la crème
brûlée à la danse était
c'était une de mes grandes soeurs avec
le chalumeau comme ça où elle le faisait
à l'ancienne comme disait jean pierre gp
comment elle faisait mais en tout cas
c'était alors on peut les mettre au four
et s'est exilé il ya le sucre la le
chalumeau qui se vend maintenant
puisqu'il faut être il faut être bien
équipé des fois un petit chalumeau ou
alors avant on mettait avec un tison
et votre seraient vous a refilé la
recette
mais séoul avait énormément je la fais
mais à chaque fois j'ai moi j'ai
l'impression de c'est un peu snob ce que
je vais je veux dire mais il faudra
juste un petit truc au fait pour que ce
soit ma recette voyez le truc c'est quoi
passer mon fric alors là la petite
touche là pour je mélange les sucres au
fait vous savez au dessus sucre roux
sucre blanc voilà
voilà voilà on va le savoir grâce à vous
que j'ai à vous tous de nous avoir suivi
on se retrouve la semaine prochaine pour
une nouvelle émission sur lcp